pour ça je vous amène maintenant au
festival de cannes avec maggie roubaud
et rené plus tôt en janvier il y avait
deux films en compétition
journal intime un film hongrois et
vigiles qui est néo zélandais ne m'a
guère au bo s'est intéressée à l'aspect
économique de ce festival pour voir si
les cannois en profite vraiment calme
sous la pluie n'a plus tout à fait le
même visage et le festival qui devient
frills joue un peu à cache-cache
comédien metteur en scène bout de la
croisette le bain de foule devenant un
bain de trous d'un hôtel à l'autre nous
avons quand même fait des rencontres de
bernard giraudeau à bernard pierre
donnadieu en passant par charles gérard
claude lelouch et la belle a ni du pays
à cannes les marchés se sont au fil des
années multiplié au festival du cinéma
se sont ajoutés le midem le mip tv et
cetera et cetera
ces manifestations qui draine beaucoup
de monde ont-elles des retombées
économiques importants et ce festival
subit-il les effets de la crise eh bien
les festivaliers sont paraît-il
nettement moins prodigues cette année
même dans les cas traitement
cette année par contre le festival est
un petit peu nous si j'ose dire en ce
sens que beaucoup de réservations faites
depuis de nombreux mois ont été annulés
au dernier moment où la durée des
séjours s'est considérablement réduit
pourquoi selon vous
je crois qu'on est le cinéma et comme
toutes les autres branches toutes les
autres sociétés ont réduit un petit peu
les budgets on essaye de réduire les
frais est ce que le festivalier déplace
facilement ou au contraire le
festivalier où ils dépensent quand même
puisque c'est les compagnies qui payent
donc il a quand même le budget pour
dépenser son budget aussi important que
celui des autres années ils font plus
attention épouse avance mais à cannes il
n'y a pas que des palaces petits hôtels
et pensions de famille récolte aussi un
peu de la manne cinématographique
une manne qui n'offrent pas que des
aspects bénéfiques
vous allez le voir des bons et des
mauvais c'est à dire au point de vue du
festival des gens nés festival sont très
bien journaliste ça ils sont très bien
mais maison qui gravitent autour des
gens moins recommandables qui volent et
qui lui permet un peu y ait une qui
partons pays non on n'en a pas eu mais
disons que beaucoup de vols où ils sont
là pour ça d'ailleurs
mais en dehors de l'hôtellerie et de la
restauration il ya le prêt-à-porter
car il existe une messe de propre à la
côte d'azur des modèles conçus par des
créateurs de la région l'une mode
ensoleillé que l'on découvre dans la
plupart des boutiques et qui s'accomode
fort mal de la pluie en principe nous
avons beaucoup d'étrangers mais là vu le
temps aujourd'hui c'est plutôt calme
oui mais en fait la femme et du monde
voilà la mène du monde et que le
festivalier dépense beaucoup au
contraire est-ce qu'il loyal torse plus
loin il y as étrangers dépensent
beaucoup le français un petit peu moins
mais enfin moyen d'entamer du monde
oui en fait qu'est ce qu'ils cherchent
c'est le modèle venant de la côte d'azur
oui oui puis un souvenir des souvenirs
qui ramène
et beaucoup de manières de la côte
d'azur